This book is very old
by a traveler, in 1865
who traveled
around the Arabian Peninsula
This radio was made in the 1950s, 1953
If you come closer, you'll find all the radio stations
You can say it started
a long time ago
As a child
I liked the old vintage things I saw in movies
like typewriters
old cameras
Even you when watching a movie
about the 1940s
if you see one of these pieces, you'll feel a need to touch it
to feel it
In a part of my childhood
I was very interested in trading
When I was around 11 years old
in the village where we used to live
not literally, but we would go to it at Eid
We have this custom on specific days of Ramadan
similar to Gargeea'n, we call it Hwam.
So
the candies I get
I would put aside what I don't like
and I would sell them
and I would feel good after it
since I am selling something desired by someone else
sometimes, I would even go out to the street and stop cars
and sell my sweets for those who want
I would double the price definitely
That was
the beginning of my trade
By time, I grew up with the tendency of possessing antiques
Even when I visit people's homes
and notice some remarkable pieces, I  would ask them about
I get interested, especially if they are inherited
Sometimes the same piece has some details like carved date
This is a gentleman's bowler hat
of
the late nineteenth century
This is natural leather
and the inside is of silk
Some pieces
their stories will remain unknown
and will remain lost in time
but it is enough for me to know it was owned by someone
This photo
was taken in 1985
in Rafha, near the Iraqi boarders
during the First Gulf War, or before that
I tried to find them on Twitter
I had a full name on the photo
I found someone with a similar name, and contacted him
he told me that the boy was his brother
so I will get in touch with the person in the photo
and send it to him
Nowadays, factories make
many copies of a piece
So, sometimes
these pieces lose its value
It made us lose
our appreciation of the piece
We start seeing it
like any consumed ordinary object
If it is broken,
we get rid of it
While in the past, they would get it repaired
These old pieces
belonged to people before, but they gave them up
I feel that I don't have the right to keep those pieces
I am supposed to give them away
Some pieces
the piece itself becomes
I mean its value increases over time
not in price but in value
It increases because of the story behind it
Some pieces have lovely stories
One of the old doors I had
It is nearly 70 years old
I traveled to Az-Zulfi to buy it
It was owned by
a man who had his own old museum
He had grown old and wanted to sell the door
so he told me the door's story
He said he bought this door from someone
from Asharqia
bought it with its padlock
Which means this door was locked all that time
and was never opened again